[Music]
I'm Kathy Wang senior director of
security at gate lab thank you very much
for taking the time to come to listen to
get labs journey on zero trust today and
this is my colleague Philippe and we're
gonna talk to you about zero trust so
what I want to do since this is an
intermediate level talk is make sure
everyone is on the same page with what
we mean by zero trust and then we want
to talk about the specific problems that
we face at get lab that we were trying
to address with zero trust rollout which
is one of our biggest initiatives this
year in 2019 and then of course I'll
talk about the roadmap in how we came
about building this and I definitely
want you to be able to learn from our
experience so far and take this home
with you as you build your zero trust
journey so lessons learned will also be
a part of our talk traditionally what do
we do as security practitioners we set
up a perimeter based defense system
right that's our defense in depth that
most of this security industry does and
we all know this really well it's the
hard on the outside and soft on the
inside kind of architecture where if an
attacker gets access inside your
environment they can move laterally they
can persist they can you know elevate
privileges they can do all of these
things and we know as an industry this
does not really work that well but most
of us employ this type of architecture
anyway so what I want to highlight is
you know so why zero trust right so
Google has a flavor of Zoo
trust that they've built backing who are
early 2010's and they call it beyond
Corp so if you want to read more about
that they have a ton of white papers
great websites with content this is
their flavor of zero trust I'm using the
term zero trust because every
environment has different requirements
in our case and in most people's case
what zero trust means is that all
devices that are trying to access an
endpoint or asset in your environment
needs to be authenticated and authorized
as they do so the user has to be
verified validated we have to know what
department or what role they have and
then we can decide whether they should
get access to what they're trying to
access all of these decisions by the way
are dynamic they're risk-based so it
depends on the sensitivity of the data
on the host that they're trying to
access so for example if I use my
personal device to try to access a
production level database that has
customer data on there and customer data
is high sensitivity that decision should
be a no you cannot do that you have to
use some sort of corporate managed
device to access that and you have to be
in the right role you have to be someone
who should have access to the production
DB there's somewhat a lot of confusion
about what zuo Trust is this year at RSA
how many people went to RSA ok so a
smattering of people they did a really
hilarious video you've got to look this
up where they went around RSA and they
asked people just random people
what is zero trust what's your
definition
half the people didn't know what it was
right I don't know if this is a surprise
to you but it kind of is to me because
zero trusts is one of the top three buzz
phrases that RSA this year so how does
that add up I don't know but this is
great videos hilarious so what I want to
do here is I want to define what zero
Trust is not just in case if you think
you can buy a single product on the
market
slap that into your environment and now
you've got zero trust you're wrong
and if vendors tell you that they're
wrong okay this is not a product that
you can just put in it's a process you
have to build many components and those
components and how they're built is
going to vary depending on your
environment what your users are situated
as and what your requirements are and
what kind of data you're trying to
protect the other common misconception
about zero trustus that is new that's
certainly how it came across at RSA this
year right the reality is that it's not
new way back in 2005 and maybe even
before that they were working groups of
security practitioners that had already
met talked about their problems like we
always do we love to talk about our
problems for security and figure it out
that hey we have to figure out how did
the perimeter rise our environments
because this particular crunchy on the
outside and soft on the inside kind of
model who is that working for right
pretty much no one so it's not a new
concept it's been talked about before
usually companies that implement zero
trust do it after a major breach has
already occurred that's kind of the
reality of it and
for cloud native companies of which
gitlab is definitely a cloud native
company 80% of these companies have not
implemented zero trust or even started
on the process 20% have and usually
after a major breach so I'm not you know
so what I'm saying is that make it lab
we're trying to implement this before a
major breach so what are the benefits to
having zero trust I think just putting
clear so I'm not going to go ahead and
read all of these out to you you can
read it yourself fundamental you just
need to understand that this changes the
model that traditionally we deploy
perimeters and we define basically every
endpoint in our environment as a
separate perimeter that's the idea so
what happens when an attacker gains
access to one of your users credentials
well you have multi-factor
authentication in place maybe your
hardware token for example and that will
make the credentials a whole lot less
useful for the attacker by themselves
what will happen when attackers do get
access to one of the hosts in your
environment which you know we all know
in security and this has been evolving
for the twenty years that I've been
doing security myself it's not whether
you will get compromised or not many
places do get compromised it's about
being transparent about what's happening
making sure your customers know and then
the other thing is about how you recover
from that incident that's very important
so what attackers will do is try to move
laterally into your environment once
they get in and zero trust or make that
a lot more
challenging so what we're going to see
is many more targeted attacks and it's
going to have to be very targeted it's
going to take a lot of resources I'm not
going to sit up here and tell you that
zero trusts 100% secure because then I
would be lying because security is never
100% but you have to understand it's an
ongoing process a couple of caveats I
want to make sure that everyone knows
this
you can't build zero trust in a month or
a week it is a journey it probably will
take you at least nine to twelve months
to do and that's assuming that you have
all of the corporate backing that you
need to do that right that's also part
of it I will go into a lot more detail
about that later and everything that I'm
going to talk about today all the
components that we considered at gate
lab as part of our journey it's not the
totality of everything you're going to
consider for your zero trust journey
because you will have a different
environment your users would be
different what you're trying to protect
would be different so learn from us but
don't think that this is all there is to
it so let me go into now before we
started on the zero trust journey and
deciding how we're going to roadmap and
build this out what did we have in place
already that get lab and to give you a
little bit more background about the
security team at gitlab I joined get lab
about a year and a half ago and at the
time that I joined there wasn't a formal
security team right so think about that
for a second a year and a half ago there
wasn't a security team so now we have a
team of almost thirty this helps a lot
of course but it's been a journey just
to get there
so I don't know how big your security
teams are but you know that's a factor
so what we had already one of the first
things that I set out to build was a
data classification policy and why is
that important because it's going to
govern what data is being processed or
stored in your environment and what
levels of sensitivity they are right so
for example for us customer data is of
highest priority that's going to be in a
red data pocket and we bucket eyes the
data types by red orange yellow and
green so from there we know as we build
out our environment and our zero trust
components where to focus on first right
focused on the red data first
that's the highest sensitivity so having
that policy in place and having that
blast by everybody at the company is a
great step forward we also built a
Google cloud security guidelines policy
and what that means is you know we have
an infrastructure team at gate lab that
builds get lab comm and they ensure the
availability of get lab comm which is
our SAS product and we have two million
plus users on get lab comm how do they
build that environment are they
following security best practices are
they using VP C's for example to
compartmentalize different environments
are they you know providing access
correctly and to best practices
guidelines to me a policy is just a
piece of paper unless we actually
enforce it so we use tools like Google
for study for example to enforce the GCP
security guidelines portion of it we
also built an internal acceptable use
policy because our users should know
what's expected behavior and what's not
okay behavior right in our environments
basically here the rules
play right in gitlab calm you know
production environment
without that people do whatever and you
have to rely on good intentions and
that's that's not a good idea we also
have a HR database in place and I
mention this because part of zero trust
components is making sure you know who's
who and what organization they're in and
what role Durand what access they should
have based on that role so until you
know this you cannot make that
risk-based decision that I was talking
about earlier one thing that's very
special to get lab and I I don't know
how many people in here worked at a 100%
remote company but what that means is
people are connecting from 50-plus
different countries around the world we
don't have a physical building at gate
lab that's a very very special
requirement in our case that may or may
not apply to you but what that means as
a security practitioner to me is that I
really have to focus on credential and
access management of those users
I can't monitor their home networks I
can't monitor the cafes that they're
connecting fun there is no physical
office that everyone's coming into a VPN
into that environment first before
accessing anything this doesn't work
that way
so we have to think about that portion
of it we don't do any self hosting of
any services a lot of companies run
their own email service we don't need to
that right we use three suite
we use Google Gmail and we rely on
Google's security best practices to help
make sure you know for example Google
Enterprise has a DLP feature so for
sensitive documents we might be able to
update DLP information to say hey don't
allow any document with these keywords
to be able to be sent out to the public
for example so we have to rely on third
party
sass providers for everything who don't
self host we also have an environment
where everyone is using Mac OS and Linux
we don't have Windows in the environment
you may so your mileage is going to vary
if you do because there's different
requirements there and different OSS to
deal with so we have a fairly
homogeneous environment I would call it
from a security standpoint now that I've
told you what we had in place already
let's talk about the first problem that
we're looking to solve there's going to
be a series of three problems I'll talk
about the first and the third and
Phillipe will talk about the second but
the first problem is managing those
users right well as I said we're
connecting from all over the world so
how exactly do we know who they are what
they're trying to access what type of
device are they using to access that and
is it okay for them to access that data
so we set out to answer a series of
questions in considering this problem we
looked at endpoints we need to know not
just the endpoints meaning the laptop
the user laptops or devices but the
endpoints in our production environment
and things that we manage on our own in
Google cloud for example and so we
looked at tools like up tips and collide
because we're a Linux and Mac OS shop
see this is why I said this matters if
your windows then you look at other
tools potentially but we looked at these
tools which is based on OS query which
is very important to us to gain
awareness of what those endpoints look
like building that information into an
asset databases is key right so the
other piece of
is who are these people that are trying
to connect and should they be able to
connect so having an old chart in an old
DB is something that we also have to
build and that's gonna be based off of
our HR database nice we also want to
work growing so fast as a company that
when I joined a year and a half ago I
was probably employee number 200
something and now there's over 500
people a year and a half later and in
another year we're anticipating over a
thousand so think about this from a
security management standpoint you have
people onboarding and off-boarding every
week like a lot of people potentially
and a big security risk is to have
people leave the company and then still
not be updated in your database think
about how scary that would be that's
really not ideal so being able to
onboard off board get people access to
the third-party apps that they need
access to to do their work we looked at
solution like after duo Google cloud
identity these are all solutions that
you would consider when you're thinking
about this problem we also looked at
that multi-factor authentication piece
in our case we considered Hardware
tokens right that makes credential fact
less valuable to an attacker so we
considered you be keys we considered
Google's heightened security keys so
these are all pieces that you should
also look at and how are we effectively
enforcing our data classification policy
it goes back to that right anything
that's in a red bucket that is
considered most sensitive we have to
protect that first and that's how
highest priority so these are the types
of questions that we asked for that and
now we come to problem two and filling
poor talk to you
thank you very much Gary by the way I'm
Phillip Africa our distinguished team
engineer at gate LOM I'm working in the
security we are working on the security
features of Gitlin so that's why we are
going to talk about securing our
applications so we've seen so far all 0
trusts can help us secure in or network
perimeter allowing the admins to set up
and enforce policies to protect this
network and allow users and devices to
access our resources and applications
but it does not make any sense if we
have these policies in place and
attackers can bypass them because we are
shipping insecure applications so all do
we trust what's running on our
production environments the first step
is to make sure that the applications
themselves are secure in the last year
we have switched left to this we have
switched security to the left at github
that was a huge leap ahead for us for
especially for the engineering with that
we put the security in the middle of our
process we make sure that the developers
are involved and we make sure that we
relieve the security team from this
burden with that we also make sure that
we educate the developers there is no
excuse anymore for a developer to say I
did not know all the informations are
there the vulnerability is right in the
middle of the nerve request so one we
want to introduce a new change in your
applications and deploy dilator is there
we have the remediation information
directly the merge request so the
developers can do that themselves if
they don't know to do that they can
involve the security team but only when
one needed with that we are leaving some
space and some room for the security
team to work on the very hot topics
they're the ones that are not obviously
not the longing fruits that or our tools
are able to catch and to provide for
every commit that we push for our
applications we're going to run security
checks who are going to do SAS
dependency scan in container scanning
binary tree session that we're going to
see after that dynamic application
security testing were doing the wall
package for every commit so again the
developers tf2 information they know
exactly what's going on
they know the implications of their
changes on the production environments
we want to be able also this year to add
I a stand facing if you want to take a
look on the roadmap there's a link at
the bottom of this slide you can also
reach out to us we are an open core
company we're completely transparent all
run map is public you can check out that
directly online
so our application is now secure how can
we trust what we're going to deploy for
that we are using binary authorization
which is a container security feature
that provides the policy informants and
policy enforcement chokepoint to ensure
own is signed and authorized images can
be deployed in production with that we
want to remove completely the human from
the deployment process so that the
pipeline will be the one and only way to
create images and deploy images the
signature is going to happen directly in
the pipeline phase for that we are
relying on a Google feature named binary
authorization and under the hood binary
authorization is relying on Rafa's and
Critias gracias is the service to
annotate the images and kritis is the
service to enforce the policies and
checking the signatures we are going to
use that to annotate the images that we
will deploy to production for example
with the results of the security checks
and if we find that some vulnerabilities
are still shipping in this image we can
block to deployment directly with kritis
so with the Google dynein writer ization
this is something that is upcoming
really soon and were docked footing
obviously at github or using it out to
develop code labs or again we're going
to use that or safe really soon so I
told you that the pipeline is going to
sign the image so that means the
pipeline has the right key is the
required keys and only the Python is
these keys so that means we need to be
able to trust where we store these keys
for that we are using another Google
feature named Google chemistry Google
management the key Google key management
service this service
is not available for all the users only
particular users and particular services
like the Python are able to request keys
we only have tems activated on
production environment right now but we
plants we have that on more environment
in the future so know that or deployment
chain is secure application is secure
the deployments secure you know occurs
they're a bit like life they always find
a way and they can compromise or user
records even if everything is secure
they can always use one of your users
icons if they manage to so how do we
mitigate that we can't prevent that
obviously but we can't limit the impact
of these discs compromise ations for
that were using user an entity behavior
analytics it's again a security feature
but based this time on machine learning
and data analysis we're going to analyze
all the locks all the events on the arc
all the actions on our platform in your
environment and we will do that to look
for the engine unknowns to suspicious so
for example if we have developers
working on a weekly basis they work from
Monday to Friday they are located in the
US and suddenly on a Saturday morning
3:00 a.m. we have a connection we have a
git commit coming from Russia from China
at 3:00 a.m. it's really suspicious we
need to be able to catch this to notify
the secretary and to make sure that
we're going to do further and further
investigation and even to reblock the
accounts so this is all we're remediate
at all of these features are available
on github we are again dogfooding this
is going to be part of something that we
could get app defend and again you can
check out the links that are there if
you want to see what's upcoming in the
roadmap this year that back to you get
it thank you so now that Philippe has
talked to you about securing our
applications I want to talk to you about
the third problem that we had
which is secure you get laptop home
which is our infrastructure at gate lab
this environment access both our
environment and customer data
environment right we use get lab at work
and this is part of our dogfooding
process and it's very important to us
culturally to do that dog food and
contribute to the product get laptop
Commons where over two million users
have yet lab accounts so you want to
make sure that there is trust built in
that people trust that we're protecting
their sensitive data in the repos so
what kind of information do we need to
know and what questions do we need to
ask there one thing is making sure that
we always know have full awareness of
vulnerability management of our endpoint
devices in production so we looked at
solutions like terrible dot IO in our
case just making sure that that
information is always there and who owns
what in the environment because we dog
food all of our own stuff that means
that engineers developers are setting up
their only environments for testing or
for whatever purpose and so it becomes
even more imperative for us to know what
those are
who owns that who should have access to
that so I mentioned optics earlier and
again this is a very useful tool if you
haven't looked into it
based on OS query for that we want to
make sure that we can mitigate DDoS
attacks and other types of abuse type
attacks on gitlab com so for to that end
we looked at WAAFs
right like fastly CloudFlare for example
that's something that we have to do
specific to get laptop
and then if an attacker were to gain
access how do we make it more difficult
for them to move laterally and by using
VP C's we can compartmentalize each
environment in a more clean way and then
we can use other tools to enforce any
violations to those access coming from
one environment to another and what
we've done is basically when those tools
run like for satis results will come
into slack we use slack and basically do
chat ups who were port violations and
now the security operations team can act
on those violations and alerts and then
how do we secure our environment using
Google's security best practices this is
something that Google's security
research team has thought about for a
really long time they're considered to
be leaders in this area for sure and we
want to be able to definitely use their
knowledge about security best practices
in Google cloud to secure a whole new
environment so we looked at tools like
cloud security command center that's an
ongoing process we turn it on we're
evaluating right now how that works for
us also and then we like I said earlier
a policy isn't that useful if you don't
enforce it if you don't enforce it
you're relying on users good intentions
and we know how that goes right so
people are human they make mistakes and
that's just putting it in a nice way
nice so now that I've talked to you and
Philippe has talked to you about the top
three problems that we were looking to
solve with our zero trust implementation
let's talk about Road mapping so since
zero Trust is such a big topic and it's
not something you can build right away
it takes a long time as a
process my understanding is that Google
is still building beyond Corp you know
so it's a really big project so how do
you wrap your head around where to get
started well when I started it was like
okay so there's so many components how
do I exactly want to pocket eyes that so
what I did was I worked with my team and
decided that we're going to do it in
three buckets right the first bucket is
anything that will touch store process
customer data and is managed by us so
that means I'll get lab comm
infrastructure write anything there
things like that so that's one of our
buckets that we put components into the
other pocket is endpoints employee
laptops devices that are being used to
access the environment get lab comm
production environment that are
individually managed that goes into the
endpoint pocket so every component that
goes towards securing that goes into
this pocket the third bucket
I mentioned that we don't self host
anything we rely on third-party SAS
vendors also so anything that does not
store or process customer data and that
includes like third-party apps that we
use at gitlab like slap like zoom like
salesforce like other you know
third-party apps goes into this pocket
so that's how I began to wrap my head
around or Safi how we're going to
compartmentalize this so based on those
three buckets I realized that hey
there's no reason why we have to create
a road map where it's kind of done in
serial for each bucket I'm gonna have
different components that apply to that
bucket it's okay to build these out in
parallel
that's actually more efficient that
saves you more time you can get to the
journey faster and so that's how we
decided to road map those out I'm not
going to read the whole road map or you
can see for yourself but the point of
laying it out this way that's very
important to you know make sure you take
home with you is things can be built in
parallel watch your pocket eyes how it's
gonna be so now that I've talked about
how we began to put the road map
together and start building these
components out let's talk about lessons
learned so far I mean obviously we're
not totally done building zero trust we
started and we have some components in
place but it's going to be a while
before we're completely you know at the
point where I would call done and then
maintaining right first thing to
remember it's an ongoing exercise you're
always going to get new users new
devices new endpoints every single time
that happens that information needs to
be updated in your data bases in in your
decision process who gets access to what
and with what device that's always
ongoing build each roadmap independently
figure out what buckets you're going to
have first that will be the most
efficient process to use we figured out
while putting the roadmap together that
there are certain components like
centralized single sign-on that if you
get that in place first earlier on in a
roadmap some of the other pieces that
follow will be more easily facilitated
because of the presence of that so think
about things that way as well as you put
numbers on the different components in
your roadmap what should you do first so
that what follows is more easily put in
place there's an element of user
experience that a lot of people don't
realize or talk about with building out
their
trust you need to make sure you don't
impede business processes right I mean
if you have zero trusting place but
people can't get the work done that's
going to be a big No and as a security
practitioner and a security team you're
be under a lot of fire for that kind of
thing right so think about the user
experience as you go along in our case
we decided to go with octa for single
sign-on solution and that really really
helped facilitate the on-boarding and
off-boarding process and our our sales
and our marketing teams they were really
happy with that because they have so
many third-party apps that they use that
they didn't want to like sign into each
one individually right separately it
made for a really really good user
experience right off to start it helps
the build user trust which will then
help you be able to rule out other
components later on which may introduce
more friction in the day-to-day work
process you know I'm not going to sit up
here and tell you security never
introduces friction or does but the idea
is to minimize it make sure people trust
what you're doing and they will they
have a positive experience at the
beginning and then you know you can
introduce other parts of it but always
think about that as a security
practitioner we realized that there's
serious automation work that needs to be
done to make these risk-based decisions
data has to be pulled from or DB asked
that DB all of this components to be
able to make a decision on whether this
access is allowed or not so I do have a
team of security automation engineers my
security team and this is what they work
on how to automate all of these pieces
and that helps us scale and it's
important to scale because we're gonna
grow to over a thousand employees this
year
can't imagine these decision process is
being manual it shouldn't be your
mileage is gonna vary as I mentioned
earlier you can't buy one product slap
it in how you got your trust you have
different requirements most likely maybe
you're not a hundred percent remote
maybe 50 percent of your employees come
to a physical office every day so one
size does not fit all and as I mentioned
earlier who goes beyond pork is a flavor
of zero trust it's a really good
learning experience to read all of the
white papers that they have it's really
great but you know at the end of the day
they're Google they have a different
environment than what we had so you
couldn't do a sappy the same thing
doesn't work one size does not fit all
and I want to also emphasize that for
some of you who maybe come from more
mature environments where the company's
been around for 20 years for example and
parameter based protections are already
put in place it may be more of an uphill
battle for you to you know lobby with
zero trust I mean everyone wants it and
everyone knows that it's a good model
not perfect nothing is but you may face
more resistance because people don't
like ripping up what's already there
right that's that's difficult so that's
um
maybe a political battle for you and you
know in get labs haste because we're
we're growing so fast a year and a half
ago we didn't have a formal security
team things are different so I want to
make sure that you know that
[Music]